The U.S. government is really
worried about China’s ambitions
when it comes to making microchips.
But so far - China has NOT gotten its hands on a
very important machine sold by just ONE company.
In a previous video, I talked about
how Taiwan Semiconductor Manufacturing
Company makes over 90% of the smallest
and most sophisticated chips in the world.
Their semiconductor chips power everything
from fridges to F-35 fighter jets.
In other words, they make civilization function.
Well, people who watched the
video pointed out that TSMC
cannot make their chips without one
piece of equipment. And it’s true.
TSMC cannot make its chips without a $150 million
dollar machine from a Dutch company called ASML.
ASML’s high-end equipment prints the tiny
features that form the basis of TSMC’s microchips.
Microchips are made by building
up billions of tiny transistors.
An ASML machine patterns the finest lines on the
microchips using a method called lithography.
The projection system shrinks and
focuses the pattern onto a silicon wafer.
After the pattern is printed, it moves
the wafer slightly and makes another copy
on the wafer. They are built up layer
by layer, like layering a cake except
MUCH more complicated because this involves
up to 100 layers with nanometer precision.
The more transistors can be added to a
chip, the more powerful the chip becomes.
ASML is the only company in the world that makes
the machine need to print advanced microchips.
It manufactures the equipment at its
factories in Veldhoven, Netherlands.
The company was founded in 1984 as a joint
venture between the electronics giant Philips
and the Dutch chip-machine
manufacturer ASM International.
ASML is now an independent company.
It has a monopoly on EUV lithography,
“extreme ultraviolet light” - an extremely short
wavelength of light that can create even tinier
circuitry than is possible with conventional
lithography which relies on Deep UV. (DUV)
EUV light doesn’t occur naturally
on earth – only in outer space.
So ASML must generate it somehow.
To generate the light, a CO2 laser fires two
laser pulses at a drop of tin, vaporizing it. The
tin vapor becomes plasma which emits EUV light.
This happens at a rate of 50,000 times a second!
The machines are assembled in clean rooms
containing zero dust. These rooms are 10,000
times cleaner than outside air. Even the smallest
speck of dust that ends up on a wafer can ruin it.
The company’s decision to switch to EUV light
in the nineties gave it an astounding advantage.
It cost billions of dollars to make
the radical switch in light sources,
but the effort has paid off big time.
ASML is now valued at around $193 billion dollars.
The EUV equipment is sold to the largest
chipmakers in the world: TSMC, Samsung, and Intel.
Every one of its machines has over 100,000 parts.
They’re shipped in 40 freight containers,
20 trucks, and three Boeing 747s.
Like the rest of the world,
China also relies on ASML machines for Chinese
companies that are producing semiconductor chips.
But in 2019, the Trump administration
successfully lobbied the Dutch government
to block shipments of ASML’s most sophisticated machines to China,
and the Biden administration has shown
no signs of reversing that policy.
However, ASML is NOT restricted from
exporting slightly older technology to China.
ASML’s older deep ultraviolet (DUV) systems
are a generation behind the EUV ones but still,
the most common way to make less advanced chips.
In 2021, 16% of ASML’s sales went to China,
around $2.2 billion dollars’ worth. The
company expects similar figures for 2022.
Washington has been trying to hamper
China’s chip-making progress in many ways.
When President Biden signed the CHIPS Act
in August, it included a caveat that if TSMC
or other chip companies want billions in U.S.
subsidies for building new plants in America,
they have to agree not to sell
their most advanced chips to China.
Washington has also been pushing ASML even to stop
shipping its less sophisticated
chip-making machines to China.
This could deal a serious
blow to Chinese company SMIC
which has reportedly been making
7-nanometer semiconductor chips
that are only a generation behind the 5-nanometer
ones manufactured by TSMC and Samsung.
If Washington gets its way, even ASML’s older
lithography equipment could be banned from China.
China could start producing its own lithography
systems if it wants to become self-reliant.
However, analysts believe it
would take China at least a decade
to build its own equipment
that could rival ASML’s.
ASML’s CEO Peter Wennink believes it
will be difficult but not impossible.
He says: "I am not saying it cannot be done,
because I know the laws of physics are the
same in China as they are here. Never
say never. They will certainly try."
Sophisticated machines like a lithography
system cannot be built without brilliant
engineers who have mastered STEM.
If you’d like to brush up on your math,
science, and computer science skills, Brilliant
is a great way to learn interactively.
(Cindy on camera working through the Logic
courses) I use Brilliant myself to help
improve my critical thinking skills
by going through their Logic courses.
I've noticed my viewers especially love the
Computer Science Fundamentals course where you can
learn to program drones in an Amazon warehouse.
There's something for everyone:
You can solve puzzles with science
through their Scientific Thinking course.
Or practice Everyday Math by
seeing numbers in a new light.
There are no tests on Brilliant,
and it’s for people of all experience levels
- whether you’re a student or already working.
If you get stuck, you can view the
explanation to see where you went wrong.
Brilliant is FREE for you to try out if you
head to the custom link in my description:
brilliant.org/newsthink
And the first 200 people who sign up with my link
will get 20% off Brilliant’s annual Premium
subscription which gives you access to all of
the offerings including the most advanced courses.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.
If the current state of the world
leaves you feeling stressed,
and you’d like to be able to relax and get
better sleep, there is a way to feel better.
I used to have a lot of problems sleeping.
But ever since I’ve been taking
Magnesium Breakthrough from
BiOptimizers, my sleep has been better.
I’ve been taking their pills every
day with my dinner since January.
I’m more relaxed and less stressed during
the day which is really helpful because
making these videos demands a lot of my attention.
What makes magnesium breakthrough stand out
is that there are no synthetic ingredients.
All of the ingredients are naturally derived.
When you get all seven critical forms of
magnesium as you do with Magnesium Breakthrough,
your body gets a serious upgrade so you
can feel better throughout your day.
If you head to magnesiumbreakthrough.com/newsthink
you’ll save an extra 10%.
My custom link is in my
description and pinned comment.
And don’t forget to use my promo
code: NEWSTHINK10 at checkout.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.